Sara L is fighting for her faith or at
least her interpretation of her faith
she made the decision to veil her face
years ago but from August the first if
she does so in public
she'll be breaking the law a violation
of her personal rights in her opinion I
feel very disappointed I feel like I
thought we lived in a free society where
people can believe what they want and
they can wear whatever they want as as
long as they don't hurt other people and
I just get the feeling that and I'm that
I'm under attack somehow that like I
can't be myself
Sara was born and raised in Denmark by
Turkish parents her niqab is for her an
expression of her piety the upcoming ban
prompted her to become an activist she
and her fellow activists are trying to
win support for a demonstration in
Copenhagen's Narborough district an area
where many migrants live and they're
getting that support I think it's a
violation of Human Rights
and I don't think anyone should decide
what people should wear just one other
time when men are deserting where women
are supposed to be wearing so it's just
ridiculous he won't help anyone I think
you're kind of pushing them more away
from society I think it's important
cut you except that there there's like a
cultural difference sarah has come to
Parliament to confront one of the
initiators of the face covering ban mass
Fuu letter he's a representative of the
governing conservative Venstre party and
he maintains that all face veils ought
to be banned although fewer than 200
women in Denmark where a niqab or a
burqa the full body covering they find
no middle ground we live why we need to
legislate against the values I'm saying
we live in Denmark very safe in Denmark
we have the freedom of religion the
discussion escalates into an argument
the niqab is a symbol of religious
freedom to some and of oppression of
women to others both sides hurl
accusations of totalitarian thinking the
carpentry job other garments of that
thought are all instruments to an end
and that end is social control of women
and the Nullification of the female
gender and we want to fight that I feel
like this lies Islamophobic it's trying
to make life difficult for Muslims and
it's basically racist and I just felt
like must prove that the ban on face
coverings is one of several laws the
government says it is introduced in an
effort to integrate immigrants some
critics say it will only divine society
further and anyway veils are rarely seen
in the streets of Denmark
not even in the imam ali mosque at
Friday prayers the veil issue is a hot
topic even among the men and they
actually approve of the ban against best
covering but about your heritage okay
about the other parties it's okay but I
won't be covering no I'm against it
totally we are Muslim sitting there in a
western country Danish Muslims as much
as we can inside the limit of Islam if
you want to participate in a democratic
society then it will give you a lot of
troubles if you want to live a very
isolated life then it's your choice
this Muslim community is a liberal one
they tend to reject the new camp the
Imam of the mosque also points out that
veiling the face is not a religious duty
some doesn't say it's obligatory to
actually wear the veil to cover your
face but if a woman chooses to do that
that's her fee what she can do that
personally like my opinion is the same
as Islam that women should wear modest
modest clothes that that cover both the
hair and the body Sarah describes the
niqab as a sign of religious humility
that can be worn as an act of free will
she doesn't accept the government's
argument that women have to be protected
from oppression and isolation her veil
even caused friction with our own family
not only does our family not impose this
on us but they actually against it my
journey of the woman in Denmark that
wear the niqab have family members
against them because they choose to
practice their religion so it's the
exact opposite Sarah's facing a
difficult future in Denmark if she
remains faithful to her beliefs her idea
of religious freedom could end in her
being isolated within our own four walls
you